and so now she can't completely close
her eyelids oh and she has to roll her
eyes and look as far back as possible to
sleep oh but she got a refund look at
that great look at that picture though
everybody ready this is only for people
who listen to the latter part of the Tim
into pod guys with all the wrestling
references ready here check this out you
ready this will be fun
rest in peace right Brian now you know
what that is right yeah you know that
that's the Undertaker when he rolls as
rest in a chin could you bring up some
YouTube footage no no no second Brian
this is the kind of fun stuff will be
doing on our pod yeah when we put that
together we'll get some bread and some
butter and I'll be right best things
real to me well that's real right okay
guys I mean it's something that I
believe that's seething over the art
form you will rest in peace right there
no no up a bit that's the one okay so
she's that's her and she did very good
yes well I'm sure that's not helpful for
her but all right thanks that's really
funny then I'm gonna put that on the
Internet
okay she had botched eye surgery yeah
Banzai sir rest in peace because the
Undertaker right Brian you know the
Undertaker right it's wrestling you like
wrestling wrestling yep real wrestling
that's not the Undertaker real wrestling
and that's and we're in nature yeah
that's where and where and that's where
we you know they're out there they're
there they're in cloaks they're in the
forest and these people are literally
having gay sex in coffins okay they're
swimming in feces okay is is this Alex
Jones Harris and your friend Joe Rogan
yeah who's literally reading the George
Soros talking points and he said he'd
have me back on the show I don't need to
be on the show okay well I have sundar
pichai the CEO of Google yeah and Google
is evil and you know this because you're
part of this exact trap travesty is what
I would call it and it's a conspiracy on
what people who come to this planet just
using it as a search engines they're bad
people and they're lizards fat people
and they're not human okay do you have
any Z evidence scientific evidence for
this you have a let me tell you the
scientific evidence that I've found of
bad people of above of lizard people
[Laughter]
lizards living among us stuck and your
friend Joe Rogan yeah ooh
Joe's a brilliant guy yeah Joseph Joe
knows as much as I do
amen and and he's a well-read guy right
and a nice and he's talking about DMT
and he wants to start a concentration
camp no I don't go I don't think that's
strived onto a long time I mean where
Joe Rogan where lives up in Valencia
where he has a concentration live in
kind of less concentration tale I can
tell you that with George Soros plant
I got a clam it's just like the story of
the Scorpion and the Frog yeah I know
the Scorpion says hey to the Frog get me
across the water yeah and he gets on the
frog and the scorpion stings the Frog
yeah and the phantom frog says why'd you
sting me and he says cuz I'm a scorpion
it's in my nature
you're a it's in my nature you're a
scorpion and a joke Joe Rogan is a
scorpion all right there's scorpion
people thanks Alex
for joining us and that was a quick
little blurb by Alex Jones and I said
Alex Jones I'm on the PI we have him on
very small blurbs very small it's too
much he heats up he heats up the room he
literally heats up the room so in his
veins he gets these giant veins in the
you know the Alita fo blah blah blah and
everybody loves it because everybody
loves impersonations you know I come by
here and I do in person yeah yeah I know
I know it's a good time what is the
nicest thing Donald has ever said to you
the nicest thing Donald was that we were
mar-a-lago yeah and I was dining with
him and vodka and and Melania and the
whole finisher baron the boy was eating
chicken strips huh and and he said he
complimented me on how I ate my Caesar
salad it was out
well I like the way you eat your Caesar
salad you separate the shrimp from the
Caesar salad I know that you asked
specifically for no croutons you're
watching your carb intake and then you
eat the salad first what's the thought
behind that and I said it's important
you got to eat your vegetables and your
fruits first
they digest a little faster right yeah
so you don't want the protein underneath
yeah the pros stick in your bowel yeah
sticking and then the the the vegetables
will sit on top and then you get all
farty
yeah and Baron laughs because I said
farty and he's like I want you around
all the time you and Baron you're gonna
teach me matter throw a football you're
gonna be the man I can't be the father I
can okay so that's I'm barons Godfather
I know and I wrote the speech
gratulations you get paid to be his God
Allah it's like the toy remember that
Richard bye dudes watch the toy uh what
is the meanest thing Donald's ever said
to you oh he called me Chris Christie
once when I was coming off as jet
backwards sorry he saw my ass and he
thought it was Chris Chris ah that's me
- get back in the jet Chris you fat [ __ ]
and I was like what and he's a get in
there Chris Christie well well oh hey
what's up with a baby and then because
you really baby yeah we have all sorts
of Nick and that's the offense of
aluminum that is in all of our
medications I don't think George soon
sundar Pichai yeah who's allowing these
communists in the giant China yeah to
censor it okay so that was more Alex on
on aluminum gin so he really was
creating the Alex yes oh yeah sound
boring gets kind of crazy oh we should
play loud Jones soundboard that's right
that's right
make frogs gay [ __ ] the frogs the frogs
gay working and they're making the frogs
game to different by well he likes to he
likes to punctuate that after we you
know there are various all they are as
different versions of making the parrot
he's having a tough time right now Alex
he's sweating this is what a real human
looks like I like to eat I like to have
babies yeah I like to fight yeah chin
nutritious thing okay here comes a
nutritious their candy mouth here comes
a nutritious thought guide Kenny
and you want me to say you wanted yeah
I'm tired of getting a deep deep I can't
live on hard candy Oh parties and I'm
not running ah [ __ ] is because if I
joined the Greenies huh that'll take
votes away from the Democrats all right
well maybe I could run with a Democrat
well what does that mean is that but
they would never do that
governor what what do you say well I'm
just saying perhaps I could run with
someone who's already in the Democratic
field that's how you take out Trump and
he's a friend of mine he's a friend of
yours I'm quite fond of Donald I don't
share some of his policies you know that
yeah I live in the Baja six months out
of the year well I like that you would
run against him because you're taller
you're bigger and small all right you
couldn't Julio I as you know I have a
thousand gallons of potable water and in
a silo full of tortillas I didn't know
down in the Baja I didn't know that now
own over 300 dogs most of them are
little dogs Terriers why do you want
dogs because I surround myself with dogs
and corn and guns okay why that's my
platform that will be one of my policies
which is what seven years of corn two
guns and three small dogs for everyone
for everyone
seven years a corn seven years not use
all right how much seven years of corn
would cost that that would bankrupt the
country faster than when the the you
know the the the green new deal and I
feel like seven ears of corn or the the
national debt how much how many comets
corn in an ear each ears of corn is an
ear of corn right so that would be right
that would be I see you don't understand
your corn you probably never served in
the military
you've never had to shuck corn in the
mess hall I had that's the difference
between you and I okay but what is that
you you call yourself an American I was
a Navy SEAL how long can you hold your
breath underwater me I can hold know
the-the-the okay it's an idiotic
steampunk grandfather clock behind you
looking I can
my breath for probably two minutes I can
hold my breath for 17 minutes that seems
like a world record I don't know if
that's true well what why are you
calling me a liar I'm not calling you a
liar I probably think that tower seven
fell because it was compromised during
the 9/11 terror I don't want to get into
that fell on its own okay
minutes later yeah I know that would you
like to run for president with me me I
don't know anybody get me started I just
keep asking people to rally around me uh
yeah I don't know the first thing about
running for president well you ran for
governor yeah I kind of forgot most of
that etc yeah too many cheer shots yeah
yeah your big fella
so so what do you say Ventura Cal in
2020 I don't think so I don't have why
not I'm just not interested in blow what
are you doing what are you busy I don't
think we could win just why wouldn't we
win yeah because I'm a comedian I've got
skeletons in my closet and then they
would find out what a piece of [ __ ] I
had yeah but you'd only be the vice
president
I know but yeah just be like pence I
never go out for dinner with a woman
okay that's all you have to do is the
vice president Christ and their you know
we'll put you in some some shoes with
lifts in them yeah so you get close to
me I'm six foot four and we'll run
against the Donald he's a friend of mine
all right yeah well okay talking about
[ __ ] that's Bill Clinton say he's
down from Donald Trump um my wife
Michelle yeah pretty good right I can do
any president everybody go ahead
uh-huh [ __ ] man Oh Barack Obama no no
did that go like old go bold real old
George Washington I'm George Washington
I will not tell a lie and that's exactly
what he sounds like
no but you can listen to Lincoln's yeah
I did you could listen to Andrew
Jackson's podcast he had he had George
Washington on I'm honest Abe plugging at
it because they're trying to bury us and
thank God for President Trump who's
gonna take on all this idea now
comedians and lying CNN think you can
get Jim Acosta who's out there and I'm
Bob wall saying well there it seems to
be peaceful by the wall you're standing
by a wall yeah whoa which in my sorry
chin yeah he went crazy on the wall
things asked Kellyanne Conway did you
get anything
hey those bags aren't under her eyes cuz
she's getting a lot of sleep all right
well keeping her up my son is beluga
whale and I says to her I saw this this
Narwhal with the huge unicorn I said
massage my prostate oh that's a really
good that's what I did with the polar
bears that's really good wow man this
has become a very strange story thank
you for sharing it though and we're
really appreciative that the Kalin
bloodline runs cold and it's these are
cold-blooded aliens wait a minute and
I've seen it and you voted for Hillary
I do fog early voted for Hillary know
that she's evil
no and Jen Jen your friend Joe Rogan
yeah who I love Joe okay and we go
a long time that's right would not have
me back on the show and you were a
little crazy on the show and my my
calendar the same thing and he wants to
be on your program and you say you're
gonna reboot the brine cabbage in don't
play I was just on one of your cohorts
he's over here right Theo von
yeah where is he next door yeah but
don't don't knock on it just keep
talking about
well he's banging on the [ __ ] [ __ ]
when he's I know but alright anyway just
stick to very so Saeng so feet and he
was like oh you know once you try
stand-up bro you could be like you could
be out there with a bag of potatoes just
being gang gang and just like the I'm
working really good yeah you'd be out
there with a bag of potatoes and a and a
can of can of Cool Whip
yeah that's good so do it well you can't
just stand up comedy I want to do
stand-up comedy
well the juice your friend Joe Rogan
said that I could come out to his
concentration camp he didn't say it
Valencia understand all the people out
there and he's harvesting up their
organs no he doesn't and Google is evil
no that's not true yeah they yep and
sundar Pichai is is is is is is is is is
is in behind our ear and your friend Joe
Rogan is implanting chips it's not as he
is he's not harvesting organs
he's got harvest in Valencia and he's
got a bunch of black market doctors
harvesting he's not I'm doing Falun Gong
and found off a meditation that's
keeping their spirit clear and then he's
harvesting the organs I'm selling it to
George Soros who's reading words around
what's he doing with the organ he's and
those are being used for rich oil
magnates
Oh in the conference yes in their
cauldrons and they're eating too much
fatty foods and pork and then
hi there and then and then these health
problems and they're getting a brand-new
set of kidneys from your friend Joe
Rogan and I love Joe and he's a great
guy he's smarter than me but you're
saying he's got some he knows just as
much as I do
no and he's implanting into chips so
until chin I mean there's only a few
minutes less right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]